[موسيقى]
تنشر الولايات المتحده قوتها في مختلف دول
اوروبا خصوصا ما تعرف بالجبهه الشرقيه
لحلف النيدو وبينما كان عديد القوات
الامريكيه نحو ال80,000 جندي قبل الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا تجاوز حاليا مئه الف
جندي مع سياده واشنطن قواتها ردا على
الحرب الروسيه من بين ما تنشره الولايات
المتحده في المانيا مقر لوحده للدفاع
الجوي وكتيبه لدعم القتاليه ويبلغ عدد
جنودها هناك نحو ثمانيه و 30,000 وفق
تقارير مختلفه في الجبهه الشرقيه للحلف
وتحديدا بولندا تنشر الولايات المتحده
بشكل دائم مركز قياده متقدمه لمقر قياده
اللواء الخامس في الجيش الامريكي
عدد جنودها 10,000 و500 جندي اما في
رومانيا فتنشر الولايات المتحده بصفه
تناوبيه سريعه قتاليه في قاعده ميخائيل
التي تتخذ مركز لتدريب قوه نيته ويبلغ
جديد افرادها نحو اربعه الاف جنديه
امريكيه وفي دول البلطيق عززت واشنطن
النشره التنوبيه لقوتها المؤلفه من قوه
مدرعه وطائرات وانظمه دفاع جوي وقوه خاصه
واجمالا تجاوز عدد جنودها في الدول
الثلاثه 2500 جندي وفي ايطاليا للولايات
المتحده نحو احد عشر الفا و500 من جنودها
وتنشر بطاريه لدفاع الجوي قصير المدى اما
في اسبانيا فكانت واشنطن قررت رفع عدد
المدنرات من اربعه الى سته ويوجد باسبانيا
نحو الفي جندي امريكي وفي المملكه المتحده
تنشر الولايات المتحده سربين من مقاتلات
35,000 من الجيل الخامس في قاعده الجويه
ويوجد في بريطانيا نحو احد عشر الف جندي
امريكي
[موسيقى]